[Musique]
la sous traitance et la maltraitance
le travail que nous faisons c'est physx
c'est difficile et il ya beaucoup
d'entre nous qui sont malades
il ya donc un local ak tiendront la
tendinite et le patron il aime les
moeurs pourquoi de les avoir licenciés
de les envoyer à pratiquer de l'argent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
grande chambre 50 chambres où le devenu
18 devant de 21 selon le contrat qu'on a
signé avec la spn on peut comprendre un
jour mais ça peut pas être trois mois
six mois
et quand on travaille avec des cadeaux
comme ça on arrive à la maison on arrive
ne pas suivre les enfants on n'arrive
même pas à participer aux réunions des
des parents d'élèves
parce que je suis tout aux fatigues et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les négociations sont au point mort
depuis un certain moment depuis à peu
près en moi on est des mines nous on a
décidé d'aller manifester devant le
groupe accor le sien ici le mot du nom
pourquoi tout simplement qu'on puisse
entendre notre revendication parce que
ça fait trois mois quand même que les
coupes franches des chambres sont la
courageuse déterminée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous les immigrés nos titres de séjour
ça dépend des conditions de travail
du coup même sens que dans le cerveau et
les rocheuses obligé de rester dans des
conditions comme ça non je ne crois pas
que en trois mois on va à des célébrants
donc on est là le combat continue